use less than greater than or equal to
compare the two fractions
21:28 soar 21 over 28 and six nines or
six over nine so there's a bunch of ways
to do this the easiest way is if they
had the same denominator you could could
just compare the numerators unlucky for
us we do not have the same denominator
so we could do is we can find a common
denominator for both of them and convert
both of these fractions to have the same
denominator and then compare the
numerators or even more simply we could
simplify them first and then try to do
it so let me do that last one because I
have a set I have a feeling that'll be
the fastest way to do it so 21 over 28
you can see that they are both divisible
by 7 so let's divide both the numerator
and the denominator by 7 so we could
divide 21 by 7 and we can divide so let
me make the numerator and we can divide
the denominator by 7 we're doing the
same thing to the numerator and the
denominator so we're not going to change
the value of the fraction so 21 divided
by 7 is 3 and 28 divided by 7 is 4 so 21
28 is the exact same fraction as 3/4 3/4
is a simplified version of it let's do
the same thing for six ninths 6 and 9
are both divisible by 3 so let's divide
them both by 3 so we can simplify this
fraction so let's divide both of them by
3 6 divided by 3 is 2 and 9 divided by 3
is 3 so 21 over 28 is 3/4 they're the
exact same fraction just written in a
different way this is the more
simplified version and six ninths is the
exact same fraction as 2/3 so we really
can compare 3/4 and 2/3 so this is
really comparing 3/4 and 2/3 and the
real benefit of doing this is now this
is much easier to find a common
denominator for than 28 and 9 then we
would have to multiply big numbers here
we can do fairly small numbers the
common denominator of 3/4 and 2/3 is
going to be the least common multiple of
4 and 3 and 4 and 3 don't share any any
any prime factors with each other
so they're least common multiple is
really just going to be the product of
the two so we can write 3/4 as something
over 12 and we can write 2/3 as
something over 12 and I got the 12 by
multiplying 3 times 4 they have no
common factors another way you could
think about it is for if you do a prime
factorization is 2 times 2 & 3 it's
already a prime number so you can't
prime factorize it anymore so what you
want to do is think of a number that has
all of the prime factors of 4 & 3 so it
needs one - another 2 and a 3 well 2
times 2 times 3 is 12
either way you think about it that's how
you would get the least common multiple
or the common the common denominator for
4 & 3 well to get from 4 to 12 to get
from 4 to 12 you've got to multiply by 3
so we're multiplying the denominator by
3 to get to 12 so we also have to
multiply the numerator by 3 so 3 times 3
is 9 over here to get from 3 to 12 we
have to multiply the denominator by 4 so
we also have to multiply the numerator
by 4 so we get so we get 8 and so now
when we compare the fractions it's
pretty straightforward 21 over 28 is the
exact same thing as 9 12 and 6 9 is the
exact same thing
6 9 is the exact same thing as 8 12 so
which of these is a greater is a greater
quantity well clearly we have the same
denominator right now we have 9 twelfths
is clearly greater than 8 12 so 9 12 is
clearly greater than 8 12 or if you go
back and you realize that 9 twelfths is
the exact same thing as 21 over 28 we
could say 21 over 28 is definitely
greater than and 8 twelfths is that that
same thing as 6 nights is definitely
greater than six ninths and we are done
another way we could have done it we
didn't necessarily have to simplify that
and let me show you that just for fun so
if we were doing it with if we started
with if we didn't think to simplify our
our two numbers first trying to find a
number a color I haven't used
so 21 over 28 and 6 over 9 so we could
just find a a least common multiple in
the traditional way without simplifying
first so what is what's the prime
factorization of 28 it's 2 times 14 and
14 is 2 times 7 that's its prime
factorization prime factorization of 9
is 3 times 3 so the least common
multiple of 28 and 9 have to contain a 2
a 2 a 7 a 3 and a 3 or essentially it's
going to be 28 times 9 so let's see here
multiply 28 times 9 28 times 9 there's a
couple of ways you could do it you could
multiply it in your head 28 times 10
which would be 280 and then subtract 28
from that which would be like what 252
or we could just multiply it out if that
confuses you so let's just do the the
second way 9 times 8 is 72 9 times 2 is
18 18 plus 7 is 25 so we get 252 so I'm
saying the the common denominator here
is going to be two hundred and fifty to
two hundred and fifty-two and 252 least
common multiple of 28 and nine well to
go from to go from 28 to 252 we had to
multiply it by 9 we have to multiply 28
times 9 so we're multiplied 28 times 9
so we also have to multiply the
numerator times 9 so what is 21 times 9
that's easier to do in your head 20
times 9 is 180 and then 1 times 9 is 9
so this is going to be 189 to go from 9
to 252 we had to multiply by 28 so we
also have to multiply the numerator by
28 if we don't want to change the value
of the fraction so 6 times 28 6 times 20
is 120 6 times 8 is 48 so we get 168 let
me write that out just to make sure I
didn't make a make a mistake so 28 times
6 is 8 times 6 8 times 6 is 48 48 2
times 6 is 12 plus 4 is 16
right 168 so now we have a common
denominator here and so we can really
just compare the numerators and 189 is
clearly greater than 168 so 189 over 252
is create clearly greater than 168 over
252 or that's the same thing as saying
21 over 28 because that's what this is
over here the left-hand side is 21 over
28 is clearly greater than the
right-hand side which is really six
ninths